varicose veins are enlarged twisted
veins they usually occur in your legs
varicose veins don't usually cause
problems but if they're painful or you
don't like the way they look you may
want to seek treatment treatment may
also help prevent blood clots from
forming in the event you have a future
surgical procedure such as a total hip
replacement some patients may have
discolored skin throbbing aching or
cramping itching recurrent skin
infections bleeding or ulcers most cases
of varicose veins can be treated with
the following procedures sclerotherapy
surface treatments using laser or micro
electric devices phlebectomy and
endovenous ablation these procedures can
be done in your doctor's office require
no large cuts and have a short recovery
period you may need more than one
treatment over several weeks to see
results sclera therapy works best on
smaller veins and spider veins in this
procedure a chemical is injected into
the vein the chemical irritates and
scars the vein this causes the vein to
close off and fade away surface laser
and micro electric treatments are used
to treat smaller veins near the skin
surface in these procedures the heat
from small bursts of laser light or
electric current make the vein fade away
a phlebectomy is also used to treat
smaller veins near the skin surface
during a phlebectomy a tiny cut is made
in the skin over the vein then the vein
is pulled out and removed and the venous
ablation is a procedure to treat deeper
varicose veins in this procedure a
flexible tube called a catheter is
inserted through a small cut into the
vein the catheter is used to send heat
from either laser light or radio waves
into
the vein the heat closes off the vein
and causes it to fade away on rare
occasions your healthcare provider may
advise a more invasive procedure such as
vein stripping it's usually performed in
a hospital and may require more recovery
time usually two or three cuts are made
in the skin over the damaged vein then
the vein is tied off and pulled out
through the lower cut
as with any procedure there are risks as
well as benefits talk to your health
care provider to see what type of
varicose vein treatment may work best
for you